e
avec Yasmine Khayat.
(explosions)
- Encore une nuit de feu
et de flammes à Kharkiv, où
les frappes se multiplient,
ciblant des quartiers
résidentiels.
La place de la Liberté de
la deuxième ville d'importance
en Ukraine a été bombardée.
"Les Russes viennent nous
libérer", ironise cet Ukrainien
en soulevant un cadavre.
Les corps sont extirpés
du bâtiment administratif ciblé;
les secours s'organisent
tant bien que mal.
"Il y a beaucoup de dégâts,
de tués, de blessés, dit
ce bénévole. C'était une frappe
aérienne très probablement.
On ne connaît pas le nombre
des victimes."
- Je veux bien garder l'es
- Plongée dans le noir en raison
du couvre-feu, Inga Yatsenko,
résidente de Kharkiv, témoigne
d'une journée en enfer.
Depuis deux jours, elle est
confinée dans un couloir,
adosséadosséadossée à un mur por
et serrant son chat contre elle.
INGA YATSENKO,
résidente de Kharkiv
- Des appartements qui brûlent,
des fenêtres défoncées,
des gens blessés qui pleurent,
qui crient dans la rue,
qui ont perdu leur maison.
- Elle est sortie hier
pour acheter de la nourriture.
- Hier, je suis sortie
au supermarché pour faire
la queue pendantes
sous le bruit des tirs.
Pourtant, les gens restaient là,
ils ne partaient même pas,
ils ne s'enfuyaient même pas
parce que tout le monde avait
besoin de se faire des réserves
de provisions.
(sirène d'alarme)
- Les sirènes retentissent
partout en Ukraine; les civils
se réfugient dans les abris.
La Russie multiplie les menaces
et les attaques tout en
demandant aux Ukrainiens
d'évacuer les villes.
Plus tôt, à Kiev, une tour
de télévision a été ciblée
par des tirs de roquette,
tuant des passants.
Face à l'offensive russe,
Inga se sent impuissante.
- On est tellement petit
devant l'armée qui fonce
sur nous! On nous attaque,
on nous attaque de partout et
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c.
Je suis heureuse de ne pas faire
d'enfants pour ne pas leur faire
supporter cet enfer.
- Un enfer dénoncé par
le président Zelensky devant
le Parlement européen.
Le bo de Kharkiv
a été dénoncé comme un crime
de guerre par le président
Zelensky, qui ajoute qu'il reste
au dialog au dialog au dialog c
les Russes à condition
qu'ils cessent de pilonner
les civils.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio